whoa welcome to milwaukee
first year baby i need a couple more now
yes
i need a couple more now champion baby
good work
thank you i love you
[Music]
you guys are both coached you know how
tough it is to win in this league and
then how tough it is
to win a championship the feelings mike
budenholzer has right now
the feelings of satisfaction and pride
well you could see when he came
up to talk to malika you know
welling up with emotion and you know
he's been part of championship
teams before with san antonio as a head
coach he's had great teams
with atlanta and here in milwaukee but
to finish the job
under such scrutiny when they've been
down as you said
having to win a game seven on the road
against the nets
having to overcome giannis's injury in
the conference finals
and then down 2-0 to a great phoenix
team
he had his pride he should be very proud
of his team
he also should take great pride in the
job he's done
mark he should take a bow because this
is a guy whose job was on the line
as crazy as it sounds if he lost early
in the playoffs
he'd have been fired that was the
reports and the reports are believable
but he held together led this basketball
team didn't panic
and he's a champion and deserves the
credit and of course while one team
celebrates the other team a crushing
defeat they were up 2-0 in these nba
finals trying to win their first
championship
in the history of their franchise in 53
years but the sun's come up short
and three games down the stretch that
were winnable
but they just weren't unable to make the
play it's it's hard to tell
your team now i would imagine mark that
you know this was a great season for
them i hadn't been in the playoffs for
10 years
one of the worst teams in the league
just two years ago second worst record
in the wreck
in the in the nba but when they look
back at this it really was a special
season
it's tough to get it tonight as a former
player coach and coach
it's tough to understand that tonight
you look back down the road and
you realize how special of the season
you had monty williams
chris paul devin booker the entire
phoenix suns organization
take a bow what an incredible ride you
allowed us to join you on
and you handle it with class and
professionalism and i know
you you have pride in terms of bonnie
williams who spoke about it during the
telecast and what
the kind of man he's become the kind of
coach he's become
oh he's a terrific coach he was in new
orleans and he now is here
an even better leader of people
and i think if you're going to have to
go through a heartache like losing in
the finals
he is the exact type of guy to build his
team back up
for when they start up again here in not
very long in a couple months
you know monty williams this is a very
very good team
and they have a great core of players
and they should be at some point very
very proud of what they've accomplished
again many of those players playing in
their very first playoff
run ever the bookers the bridges the cam
johnsons
but they certainly did spectacularly as
they get to the nba finals for just the
third time
in phoenix suns history well pj tucker
acquired from houston mid-season
what an acquisition that was and look at
the joy for pj tucker
diana cooper the finals mvp
with a 50-point performance here in the
clinching game six
and it'll be dancing all night
more to come here from milwaukee as the
celebration continues
for the box